hi there I'm Alexander Rose the
executive director at the long now
foundation some of you who come to these
know that we generally play a short
movie that exemplifies long-term
thinking and can we bring the lights up
just a little bit this one is is a movie
done by a Japanese artist name is Sal
Hashimoto is done in 2003 and it's
called 1945 to 1998 and one thing I
wanted to just do a quick poll in the
audience for those of you who have not
seen this movie how many I'm going to
ask how many of you think we've
detonated less than a hundred atomic
bombs since 1945 how many of you think
we've detonated less than 500 atomic
bombs how many of you think we've
detonated less than a thousand atomic
bombs okay and how about 2,000 atomic
bombs okay
please roll the movie
I'll narrate just a little bit so up in
the top right are the months going by in
the year the bottom is the number of
detonations so you just saw Trinity now
the two bombs dropped on Japan and the
flags you'll see it come up as the
different countries do their tests
Pacific atoll test by the u.s. total
number of detonations in bottom-right
Russia gets the bomb Great Britain
starts testing notice never in Great
Britain Australia France gets the ball
also not testing in France Africa and
the Pacific atoll
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now passing 1974
[Music]
[Music]
we just passed 2,000 mark a number of
detonations
[Music]
and then the testing treaty was signed
[Applause]
evening I'm Stuart brands from the long
now foundation well you could see the
glass is half-full only one thousandth
of those was dropping on people to kill
them so far most of the time we think
about nuclear weapon is the nuclear age
sort of in terms of what's going on at
the moment terrorism now cold war then
and long-term thinking is the kind of
thing that dick Road Springs to the
subject because he's been on the beat of
nuclear weapons since his book the
making of atomic bomb and so we've seen
this kind of trend not just in terms of
the explosions on the surface of the
earth and underground explosions but how
it's actually playing out in the
technology and the politics and the
geopolitics Richard Rhodes
right here one of the things that
intrigues me about that sequence that we
just saw is the extent to which those
tests over the years were a kind of
communication very low-grade
communication back and forth between the
United States and the Soviet Union the
other thing that's intriguing and I
think hopeful in a quantifiable hard
data sort of way is that they slowed
down and essentially stopped the only
tests that have been conducted in this
century have been those tests in North
Korea it may well be that they're going
to be the last of them we will see or we
may have a few outliers like Iran that
need to express that particular national
will that particular reach for a
national prestige before they're
prepared to go any further but what I'd
like to talk with you about tonight is
where we got to after the end of the
Cold War where we are now and how we
might move from here to some more stable
state which might be the abolition of
nuclear weapons I think we'd all like
that if if it played out right or it
might not be it might be something else
but one of the things that surprises me
is how many Americans evidently think we
got rid of our nuclear weapons at the
end of the Cold War at first that sounds
ill-informed but on a more fundamental
level it's really interesting that
people would feel the connection between
the nuclear arms race and the long
cold war between the United States and
the Soviet Union and understand that
some really quite profound level there
with the end of that long conflict
we don't need nuclear weapons anymore
and at the same time the opposite
response has been present in our
government in particular an effort to
find some way to rationalize keeping all
the weapons that we built during the
Cold War or at least some large subset
of those weapons almost a process of
looking for new enemies Dick Cheney was
Secretary of Defense in the years
immediately after the cold one under
George HW Bush and he is as he's often
said someone who believes that you
should be ready for any possible future
for him there was a real effort in the
early 90s to write the Defense
Department document that would define a
more dangerous world than I think most
people here and abroad felt we had come
to and in particular there was an effort
on the part of political conservatives
to to reframe China as the coming enemy
with the potential for another cold war
with China it's been quite a struggle in
those years
to pull away from that particular
approach and to try to rethink
everything because the obvious thing to
do is to stay with whatever you have as
if somehow the future isn't different
from the present I hear from any number
of people in the nuclear weapons
business that everything is nice and
stable let's stay where we are but of
course that's not the way the future
works certainly not the way we've seen
history working let me read to you from
a speech of George kenan´s
back in the 80s really quite oppression
look and where we came to by the end of
the Cold War you remembered there was a
general crowing and the part of our
President George HW Bush that we'd won
the Cold War and although some of his
actions during his presidency were
absolutely first-class in terms of
reducing nuclear armaments in pace with
the former Soviet Union taking all of
our tactical nuclear weapons back to the
United States getting rid of all our
tactical nukes that were ground-launched
in the process clearing out all of our
nuclear weapons in South Korea which was
a real opening for North Korea to think
about maybe changing its stance but he
felt the pressure as I guess we're
pretty familiar with today of the
Republican right to take a strong stance
about all this and to say we won the
Cold War
in the sort of classic Reagan s sense
let me give you Kennan's view ten years
before that time of what we had won and
what we haven't won he's been speaking
about the development of the Cold War
between the two superpowers
it is from these great mistakes
he writes that there has flowed as I see
it the extreme militarization not only
of our thought but of our lives that has
become the mark of this post-war age and
this is a militarization that has had
profound effects not just on our foreign
policies but also on our own society it
has led to what I and many others have
come to see as a serious distortion of
our national economy we have been
obliged to obituaries
to the expenditure annually of a great
portion of our national income
for what are essentially negative and
sterile purposes the production of
armaments the export of armaments and
the maintenance of a vast armed force
establishment purposes that add nothing
to the real productive capacity of our
economy and only deprive us every year
of billions of dollars that might
otherwise have gone into productive
investment to which I would just mention
that today despite a really dramatic
reduction in the number of nuclear
weapons that we have deployed down as a
result of this latest treaty - in a
short time only about 1,200 weapons on
the US side and a comparable somewhat
larger number on the Soviet side Russian
side and yet those weapons are costing
us upwards of fifty billion dollars a
year simply to maintain and this habit
Kenan goes on this habit of pouring so
great a part of our gross national
product product year after year into
sterile and socially negative forms of
production has now Riven - the risen -
the status of what I have ventured to
call a genuine national addiction we
could not now break ourselves of the
habit without the most serious of
withdrawal symptoms millions of people
in addition to those other millions who
are in uniform have become accustomed to
deriving their livelihood from the
military-industrial complex
thousands of firms have become dependent
on it
not to mention labor unions and
communities it is the main source of our
highly destabilizing budget deficit he
goes on and the problem is made worse by
the unnecessary wastefulness of this
entire exercise by the inter-service
rivalries that caused so much
duplication of effort by the double
standard we apply to costs and results
in relation to the military economy and
the
civilian by the lack of any coherent
relationship between the criteria
Congress applies to military
expenditures and those it applies to
non-military ones to which I would just
meant add
the double standard that he mentions
he's referring of course to the system
that years to build new weapons and
acquire new armaments where the cost is
basically paid for by the government
with a with an additional profit on top
where the system is triggered so that
the weapon systems that are - that are
possibly to be built or are kind of cut
in upfront so that by the time it might
be possible or should be necessary to
eliminate them because they don't work
well it's too late it only makes sense
at that point to finish them so let's
look at what we paid for the Cold War
these are numbers they were developed by
a group of scholars in the late 90s
which I have updated to present dollars
so that you understand their their force
Carl Sagan in 1995 was talking about the
cost of the Cold War and I think summed
it up brilliantly in this one sentence
in other words everything in the United
States except the land and the share of
that total that was devoted to nuclear
weapons and and the infrastructure
around them seven point eight trillion
granted not nearly the whole but
considering that only two of these
weapons have ever actually been used in
war in the context of war it's really
quite amazing that we put so much trust
in them and devised such an elaborate
philosophical structure around the
notion that somehow a first strike in a
second strike in this strike and that
strike back and forth and around and so
forth as if it were all a bloodless
business which of course it's not
every year the American Society of Civil
Engineers prepares a report card on
America's infrastructure this is the
most recent of those report cards it is
marginally better than the one that I
first looked at which was in 2003 but as
you can see it's not I think it reflects
very accurately my personal experience
probably your personal experience of the
infrastructure we moved through and live
in the holes in the roads the crumbling
schools the bridges that fall down and
so on 2.2 trillion of that seven point
eight trillion and surely we could have
done with a few fewer nuclear weapons
than we built the 20,000 or so that we
built in fact I think we were up closer
to 40 the Russians in the course of
their years built something like 95,000
because they were operating on that
system where you were supposed to over
produce every year compared to the
previous year 110% every year and nobody
knew how to turn off the spigot and
furthermore the system in Soviet
factories was that you always put some
good pieces aside so that if you screwed
up the next year you could slip those
into the production and say I overfilled
fulfilled my quota comrade so the
numbers were even worse in their case
but I ask you to think about how
different this country would be had we
spent this 2.2 trillion to maintain our
social infrastructure rather than to
build nuclear weapons that we never used
and and in truth would never have used
every president starting with President
Truman after the end of the Second World
War
said clearly in private or sometimes in
public that there was no political
circumstance that he could imagine that
would require the use of nuclear weapons
and the same was true on the Soviet side
starting at least with Nikita Khrushchev
who in his memoirs says something like
for the first three days after they gave
me the briefing I couldn't sleep and
then I realized that I would never use
them and after that I slept what were we
doing I think it's pretty clear that for
political leaders once you make the
decision that you're not going to use
these things they become counters in a
very complicated and elaborate political
game we know what the international game
was like all through those years what
has been discussed less and when I try
to go into a bid in this new book of
mine is how much of the nuclear arms
race was for domestic consumption on
both sides on the Soviet side where
there was constantly a sense that they
were behind that we were ahead that
somehow being had mattered where nuclear
weapons in quantity are concerned and on
our side there was the constant drumbeat
back and forth between the two political
parties and it wasn't always the
Republicans who were playing the Hawks
and claiming the other side was weak on
defense you will where some of you will
recall John Kennedy's famous missile gap
which he created by refusing to get the
briefing on what we actually had and
where we actually were until after he
was elected and inaugurated at which
point not surprisingly he discovered we
didn't have one we were in fact ahead in
fact throughout the Cold War it would
have been an impeachable offense for an
American president to have allowed the
Soviet Union to get ahead of us in any
meaningful sense of the word and we
never did but those who say that we
spent the Soviet Union into bankruptcy
forget about this
we spent ourselves into a kind of
bankruptcy to although not one that we
couldn't dig our way out of fairly
easily now as I said many Americans
think we got rid of our nuclear weapons
at the end of the Cold War expressing a
common understanding that our nuclear
weapons were there because we felt
threatened by another large nuclear
power and of course we didn't but it's
also true that even a few nuclear
weapons exploded in the right context
would be a disaster not simply for the
region where those weapons were exploded
but also for the whole world the
threshold for world scale systemic
environmental effects is much lower than
we have been led to believe the
scientists who worked up the original
nuclear winter model came back to it in
this around 2006 or 7 they were curious
to see first of all if the new and
improved weather and climate models that
have been developed in response to the
concern about global warming would give
them a more nuanced and richer picture
of the classic nuclear winter where you
have a full-scale exchange of nuclear
weapons in large numbers between let's
say the United States and Russia they
did that work and they found that there
if anything their model was the
conditions the results were even worse
than they had predicted before but then
they were interested at the question of
what about a small so-called regional
nuclear war what if India and Pakistan
which became nuclear powers and
full-scale in the 1990s after the end of
Cold War what if India and Pakistan
exchanged simply 150 each Hiroshima's
sized atomic bombs the assumption in
this model was that they would
necessarily bomb each other cities they
wouldn't as we pretended to later on in
the Cold War target everything on
missile silos on the middle of Montana
or Kazakhstan they would attack each
other cities because their weapons would
only basically be useful in that context
those cities contained large volumes of
flammable materials and in fact the main
effect of nuclear weapons contrary to
what you may have heard is firing most
of the people at Hiroshima and Nagasaki
died of fire not of radiation not a
blast those have fairly limited extents
from Ground Zero but when a fireball
with the temperature of 40 to a hundred
million degrees is ignited in the sky
over a city it simultaneously ignites
all the flammable material within a very
large radius I looked at a model that
had to do with a 300 kiloton warhead
exploded over the Pentagon in Washington
if you only calculated blast it would
basically destroy everything out to the
Capitol building you those of you who
have been there have a sense of that
distance but if you count the effect of
fire of the ignition of materials by the
huge heat of the fireball everything all
the way out to the ring roads around
Washington would be completely destroyed
burned to ash nothing organic left so
it's the firestorm that causes the real
damage with nuclear weapons and if you
you is even 50 on each side 15 kiloton
Hiroshima size
bombs this by the way it shows you one
such mass fire
this was her Oshima that day but this
will show you what happens with that
hypothetical india-pakistan war
as I said this was a model that was
developed by the same scientist who
developed a nuclear winter model and
here they used the latest simulations of
weather and patterns around the world so
within a few months you have a world
where that's something like the world of
1816 when a large volcano in Sumatra
spread a pall of ash and soot around the
world it was called the year without a
summer
there were hard freezes in Pennsylvania
in July I found John James Audubon about
whom I wrote a biography a few years ago
commenting on the the conditions that
summer in eastern the eastern part of
the United States so here we are and
this is the result
20 million próxima deaths and blast fire
and radiation that's the immediate
firestorm or mass fire but then perhaps
a billion people dead because their
crops failed and they were living on the
thin margin anyway so all of us are
still at risk
all of us are still responsible all of
us have reason to be worried about
nuclear weapons in any country's hands
including our own and here are today's
inventory these numbers for Russia in
the United States will go down in the
next couple of years because of the New
START treaty that 8008 weapons if you
put them at let's say a hundred kilotons
each which is probably a pretty good
average that would be about eight
megatons eight or eighty somebody with
better numbers than I
I think it's only eight though
nevertheless the firestorms
that I was showing you between India and
Pakistan represented 1.5 megatons we
have nuclear weapons which have a larger
yield than that so the world is still
very much one where we have a problem
with nuclear weapons and where as I'm
sure you know there is an increasing
movement among national and
international leaders including
President Obama a movement to some
extent begun by this so-called four
horsemen Sam Nunn Bill Perry Andrew
Kissinger and George Shultz
that's Stanford they were trying to
think about how to commemorate the
Reykjavik summit when President Reagan
and President Gorbachev came within a
hair's breadth of agreeing to begin the
elimination of all nuclear weapons in
the world but hung up on the fact that
President Reagan felt he needed a
physical rather than a political defense
against the possibility of cheating and
because with I must say with Richard
Perle whispering over his shoulder like
Iago I've written the play about the
wreck Ubik summit which has had some
readings around the country and I went
back and reread Othello real thoughts
that all I had to do was borrow the
character Richard Perle fit the mode
perfectly but be that as it may the fact
is they did eliminate a whole class of
nuclear weapons in Europe at the time
and really began a process that I think
has been bubbling along somewhat under
the surface ever since
but these retired national American
national leaders got together at
Stanford on the 20th anniversary of
Reykjavik and began saying what do we do
now and they were particularly concerned
about the possibility of a terrorist
nuclear
but that's another place where things
have changed it used to be that
countries built nuclear weapons
countries that were potentially at risk
of retaliation if they attacked another
nuclear power or even a client of a
nuclear power with the end of the Cold
War with the spread of nuclear
technology it's theoretically now
possible for a sub-national group
assuming it can acquire the necessary
quantities of highly enriched uranium or
plutonium but probably highly enriched
uranium because it's very hard to make a
bomb out of plutonium takes a very
sophisticated design and it's fairly
easy to make one with highly enriched
uranium but if they could acquire such
material then theoretically they could
do the work of rather simple work of
putting together a weapon and the effect
as many people have discussed of a even
a small yielding let's say 1 kiloton
1,000 tons of tnt equivalent weapon
exploded in a major American city would
be world scale economically and in many
other ways I think we would probably arm
ourselves to the teeth rather than sit
down and say this is madness let's
figure out a way out of this I don't
know so would there have been in the
years since the end of the Cold War a
number of efforts to figure out how we
move on one of the most interesting was
the Canberra Commission that was called
together by the Prime Minister of
Australia in 1995 in 1996 a group an
interesting group of international
figures of various kinds members of the
Swedish parliament the man whose hands
are spread here is Richard Butler who
was a special ambassador from Australia
for arms control and the elimination of
nuclear weapons a very special position
and he was the chair the conveyor
Commission what came out of the
Commission besides some very good ideas
about how to move toward eliminating
nuclear weapons was what Richard calls
probably the most important single thing
that the committee did and that was to
define what he calls the axiom of
proliferation to Richard Butler this is
the fundamental fact about the political
realities today and in the future that
as long as any state has nuclear weapons
others will seek to acquire them when
President Obama spoke in Prague in the
spring of 2009 he made a statement that
could qualify probably deliberately
qualifies intentionally qualifies as a
corollary or a restatement if you will
and that was if we believed that the
spread of nuclear weapons is inevitable
then in some way we are admitting to
ourselves that the use of nuclear
weapons is inevitable so pleasant as it
would be to believe that nuclear weapons
are off the table then all we have to
worry about now is North Korea and Iran
the only one of which actually has any
nuclear weapons at this point the fact
is that so long as nuclear powers exist
in the world others are going to want to
have weapons to protect themselves
against those nuclear powers indeed the
reason the United States in 1940 and 41
and 42 decided to develop the atomic
bomb in the first place is because we
believed with some reason that Nazi
Germany was working on a bomb and as one
person said who worked on the bomb the
prospect of a Third Reich ruling the
world for a thousand years with nuclear
weapons was absolutely abhorrent and
tenable later of course we discovered
that the Germans had taken a false turn
and had not actually got very far at all
in working on nuclear weapons but we
didn't know that when we began one other
thing that Butler Richard Butler says
about his axiom and that applies to
President Obama's corollary is that as a
fundamental legal and political right in
international law for one nation to
maintain a nuclear arsenal and demand
that other nations either not develop
such an arsenal or eliminate the ones
that they have is simply beyond the pale
that means that in many ways the United
States and to a lesser degree the former
Soviet Union Russia are the worst
offenders not Iran not North Korea not
Libya or Pakistan or India we are we
maintained the largest Arsenal's in the
world of nuclear weapons where of course
the good guys and indeed in the George W
Bush administration for eight years the
theory of nuclear weapons possession was
it's okay if the good guys have them
it's only wrong for the bad guys to have
them which is why the George W Bush
administration aided India in the
development of its nuclear power
capabilities knowing full well that that
would add to the knowledge of the
technology necessary to build and make
more sophisticated India's arsenal
against the idea that you need nuclear
weapons to protect you against other
countries it's an idea that originated
in Germany in West Germany and the 1970s
under Billy Brandt and his advisor Aegon
Barr
they were looking at a way to solve the
dilemma of a divided
Germany and as they thought through this
very difficult question they came to the
understanding that it was only with the
Soviet Union and not against the Soviet
Union as Konrad Adenauer had been that
they were going to achieve their goal
and out of that came the idea as it was
expressed a few years later by a UN
Commission in 1982 of what they called
common security this is that statement
that security can now only be achieved
in common no longer against each other
but only with each other shall we be
secured what that meant to them in
Europe at the time was that they signed
a treaty with the Soviet Union that all
the existing borders of the states of
Europe would be official and and
accepted by all the parties which looked
to the Russians as if Germany was
agreeing to remain divided permanently
but in fact it was the beginning that
discussion and this idea was the
beginning of the end of the Soviet
occupation or domination of Eastern
Europe the Palmer Commission which was
the UN Commission I mentioned and which
issued a paper on the subject in 1982
called common security said this all
states even the most powerful are
dependent in the end upon the good sense
and restraint of other nations everyone
has a shared interest in survival and in
the long run they added no nation can
base its security on the insecurities of
others these ideas and I don't know the
extent to which really brought in a gun
bar and others knew this but these ideas
go back originally to Niels Bohr the
Danish physicist who when he learned of
the American bomb program thought his
way through
to the inevitable conclusions of the
development of nuclear weapons I will
come back to him let's see I'll come
back to him at the end and what he said
but I just want to make the point that
Bohr saw that when you have an energy
source that is essentially unlimited
that the whole basis for war which is
that one side accumulates more
destructive force than the other in the
form traditionally of cannon shells and
bombs and bullets and all the rest that
the other side finally capitulates
rather than be destroyed but if both
sides have the capacity to tap the
energy and the nucleus of atoms millions
of times more per gram of material than
the chemical energy that had been used
for centuries to make weapons of war
you've short-circuited the whole process
so when Dora found his way to fact let
me skip forward to this
when Bohr found his way to President
Roosevelt in 1944 hoping that what he
had come to understand about this
process and these developments would
convince the world's three wartime
leaders in the West
meaning Churchill Roosevelt and Stalin
that rather than go through the
incredible expense and danger of a
nuclear arms race they should sit down
at the outset and realize that no such
race could ever be won that the only
possible outcome would be either
stalemate or the risk of mutual suicide
and essentially the destruction of the
human world Bohr tried to explain that
to Roosevelt and Roosevelt was
interested
he went to Churchill and Churchill threw
him out of his office
Churchill was Churchill's country was
bankrupt by then
and the notion and for Churchill the
only way he could see Britain to survive
was if it maintained to clear weapons
itself and allied itself with the United
States which is of course how things
played out but in the process the arms
race that bore forced saw coming came
and it was only believe me by the
thinnest of margins that we made our way
through the Cold War without a Cuban
Missile Crisis erupting to the full
extent that it might have erupted there
were other Cuban Missile Crisis like
near misses all the way through the Cold
War there was one for example in 1983
when President Reagan moved
intermediate-range nuclear missiles into
Europe following the failure of
negotiations to convince the Russians to
remove theirs from Eastern Europe and
then we had a large NATO exercise that
fall called able Archer which was going
to include a practice and run-up to
nuclear war which the participation of
national leaders such as Margaret
Thatcher and the Soviets not
surprisingly knowing that one way you
started war is to pretend you're having
a war exercise and then go from there
I was the standard way the Soviets
started wars thought that perhaps the
United States was in the process of
trying to set up a first strike against
their country and it was only at the
last minute when President Reagan got
word of this development and sent word
to Moscow no that's not what we're doing
and stood down the exercise that the
Russians backed off a little bit and
that crisis was over and I've talked to
people who have reason to know in our
government and told them that story or
reminded them of that story and they've
said oh there were a lot more events
like that
come out yeah but short of that Boris
saw the nuclear weapons and the huge
amounts of energy that were released in
the process we're going to short-circuit
war that you'd simply couldn't find Wars
anymore and I think that's the real
message of the last 60 years the United
States was prepared to lose a war with a
small third world country Vietnam North
Vietnam rather than introduce nuclear
weapons and risk a response from the
Soviet Union Soviet Union was prepared
to lose the war in Afghanistan under
similar circumstances the weapons were
not deterrent if by deterrent you means
something that is of use they deterred
it when Washington now likes to call the
existential level meaning they
threatened your very existence and
therefore you were careful about when
and how you might use them but they
never deterred in the process of
negotiations in fact the North
Vietnamese famously at the Paris peace
talks told Henry Kissinger we knew we
could win because we knew you wouldn't
use nuclear weapons on us and short of
that we knew we could win and they did
so let me go then to the question of how
we might proceed toward a safer world
about with with nuclear weapons under at
very least reduced numbers and much
greater control and these are steps that
I as I indicate have to some degree in
the earlier numbers actually already
begun securing all nuclear materials as
I said earlier you cannot make nuclear
weapons without highly enriched uranium
or plutonium 239 no one else has figured
out any other materials that could do
that job some of those materials in the
former Soviet Union were dispersed among
a lot of laboratories under a system
that the Soviets called guns guards and
gulags basically the whole country was a
prison camp and under those
circumstances nobody could get out just
as nobody could get in
so they really weren't worried about
signing out some highly enriched uranium
to a lab director it's somewhere in the
vast Soviet Union who wanted to do some
experimental work with it because they
knew there was no place else it could go
when the walls came down when the fences
came down when the borders opened
suddenly the former Soviet Union found
itself in the same situation we have
been in in this country since the
beginning of the nuclear age and before
which is open porous borders so we had
devised systems for keeping track of
every last gram supposedly we recall the
plutonium Factory and Boulder Colorado
which had a bunch of plutonium in the
pipes but that's allowed for and
understood as part of the process in any
case we had real-time accounting system
so that whenever a piece of material was
moved from one place to another or
transformed chemically or whatever was
done with it it was accounted for in the
record we had systems that protected not
only from attacks from the outside but
also theft from the inside which is
something the Soviets had not protected
for it because again where would you go
someone gave you a million dollars in
the former Soviet Union what good would
it be we've been working with the former
Soviet Union since 1990 in a process
that has cost the United States very
very well invested several billion
dollars it's been slower than it might
have been because politics intervened
most of the contractors were required by
Congress to be American companies who
know how all this goes but the process
has been ongoing and Sam Nunn through
one estimates that about 60% of the
former Soviet Union's nuclear materials
are now under secure lock and key stage
reductions you know we've been doing
that and that we're now down with the
New START treaty to a relatively low
number in the thousands but as you saw
from the india-pakistan graph we really
need to be down
tens at most it will take a while to get
there and both the United States and
Russia are now beginning to talk about
the fact that other countries are going
to have to come in as well
France has perhaps 300 nuclear weapons
England about 240 Israel anywhere the
estimates are all over the place but the
best estimate is 80 to 100 and so forth
and in the process of so President Obama
has proposed a four-year program to
secure all the world's nuclear materials
within the next four years that may be
ambitious I don't know but it's at least
underway and people are aware of it and
it's the right first step then
simultaneously as has been going on
reducing our nuclear arsenals at the
same time and this is farther along than
you might guess a worldwide technically
technologically sophisticated
unconstrained inspection system we have
a lot of the system in place as a result
of the nuclear test ban treaty which has
to be policed and therefore there are
all sorts of sensors underwater and in
on satellites and elsewhere that keep
track we have an underwater sensing
system that can track in fact this is
the test of the system to be sure it
works right
fifty pounds of dynamite exploded as far
as five thousand miles away so the
chance of any country cheating on an
agreement about eliminating nuclear
weapons is really quite small by the
time the whole system is instrumented to
a far greater level even than the system
we're already building nuclear
weapon-free zones have been one of the
ways that a lot of the world has already
cleared out any possibility of nuclear
weapons I think most recently all of
Africa put together a treaty that made
it into unit's entirety a nuclear
weapons free zone eventually you crowd
them into the corners and then you have
to deal with those corners one of the
nice things about the idea of a nuclear
weapon-free zone in the middle
East is that it might allow Israel to
eliminate its considerable nuclear
arsenal without ever having to
acknowledge that it has one that's
actually serious but then we're left
with the hard cases and the two hardest
cases are I really left out of this list
I think the hardest case is going to be
the United States of America myself and
I mean that with dead seriousness I
think we are going to have more trouble
agreeing to eliminate our last nuclear
weapon than any other country partly
because we're we seem to be a country
that easily falls into fear partly
because thread inflation and fear
mongering is part and parcel of our
domestic politics it's going to be a
long time I think before that last
nuclear warhead is disassembled and
thrown away nevertheless we know that
these countries have particular problems
with their security needs that are going
to have to be addressed by the rest of
the world
Butler with your Butler proposed the
idea that there be a Security Council of
the UN for nuclear matters that doesn't
have a veto which would mean of course
that no one on the council could prevent
a majority from acting and then one that
I'd never see anyone talk about but that
is in fact one of the reasons why I
think we're going to be a hard case if
the rest of the world and we eliminated
all our nuclear weapons we would be
proportionally more powerful than we are
now
because we have such a huge conventional
military and conventional weapons
systems indeed the reason small
countries like North Korea and Pakistan
and others have gone nuclear in the past
or tried to has been because of their
fear of the United States as
conventional force if Saddam Hussein had
indeed developed nuclear weapons would
we have invaded him on the ground twice
as we did I think in highly unlikely so
that has to be resolved and the United
States has to be willing to discuss
reducing the level of our conventional
for
the there's a chapter in my book
actually two chapters devoted to the
first war with Iraq back in 1991 I was
fascinated in thinking about it for this
talk to realize that even though as it
turns out we thought they had nuclear
weapons this is 91 now not later we
didn't think they had nuclear weapons
George Bush made that up because he
didn't want to stop at the border after
clearing them out of Iraq I mean of
Kuwait he wanted to go on into Iraq and
weaken its military but he needed a
reason and his reason which was invented
was that the Iraqis were working on
nuclear weapons we didn't know that at
the time after the war was over we
discovered lo and behold they were and
it was a very interesting time when
inspectors under United Nations control
from the International Atomic Energy
Agency roamed all over Iraq with
considerable resistance from the Iraqis
varying year-by-year and found what they
had made what they had hidden what they
were already blowing up out in the
desert somewhere and blew up the
building sent all the original uranium
and materials out of the country and
basically cleaned the place out I
mentioned that because at some point in
time if a country like Iraq resists the
world's demand that they eliminate their
nuclear capabilities as part of a move
toward complete elimination of nuclear
weapons that's the kind of inspection
system that will have to be applied and
I think that speaks also to the question
of what if someone cheats I mentioned
that to Richard Butler and he said why
the whole world would come down upon
such a person with a wonderful
Australian accent I can't imitate and
he's right it wouldn't be a question of
someone cheated and the neighbors around
him let him get away with it lalala it
would be the whole world would be
concerned about any particular country
that tried to steal a march on
rest of the world and to that point what
we're really talking about when we talk
about the elimination of nuclear weapons
given the fact that the knowledge is
with us and will stay with us as long as
we maintain that knowledge we're really
talking about delayed deterrence if we
decided today that we wanted to make the
world a little safer we could agree with
Russia that both sides would take their
warheads off their missiles and move
them into the empty silo next door and
that would mean that it would take about
an hour to get the missile ready to
launch and you'd have an hour instead of
six minutes or 15 minutes whatever the
number is if you wanted to go a step
farther you could take off the warhead
and put it in a truck and taken 60 miles
down the road and then it might take
several a day or two you see where this
goes
ultimately if you've eliminated the
physical warheads disperse the materials
whatever you need to do by agreement
with your neighbor countries there's
always the possibility of reconstituting
a nuclear arsenal and under those
circumstances so long as that was secure
it really doesn't matter whether
deterrence works in 30 minutes or three
months as long as it's certainly so as
the Acheson lilienthal so-called Burak
plan committee worked out all the way
back in 1946 at the very beginning of
all of this ultimately in a world where
everyone has agreed not to build nuclear
weapons attempting to do so as robert
Oppenheimer explained to Bernard Baruch
who said where's your army how are you
going to police this treaty up and I
were said well if another country tried
to cheat that would be an act of war and
every other country in the world would
essentially be technically then at war
with that country and you might try
diplomacy and you might try negotiation
and you might try conventional war which
would probably be sufficient but if all
else failed you could reconstitute your
own nuclear
on your own soil and in the end we would
only be back to where we are now that's
why the notion that it's impossible to
make this happen
strikes me as so unrealistic it's much
more realistic to see how indeed it is
possible within the context of the
hardest kind of realpolitik thinking a
Defense Department what do we need to do
to make this solid not of idealism or
any of those qualities that people seem
to think are somewhat less than than
real even though they drive the world
more recently I saw a paper just
yesterday by a British scholar talking
about the idea of a virtual nuclear
arsenal this is in a way a sense of sort
of like what you'd have on the way to
zero but the idea is simply that you you
get rid of most of your weapons
everybody does and you have a few
dismantled stored away somewhere and
then if you need them you can put them
back together and do threaten or
whatever you're going to do with them so
I don't even have to go into detail
about that it really was assumed within
the context except of course it has a
different end point it says we're not
going to get rid of nuclear weapons
we're going to keep a few in a
disassembled State this is basically by
the way the way Pakistan and India
maintained their nuclear arsenals I
talked with the Pakistani general in
Monterrey a couple of years ago who said
well you know we don't have first strike
capabilities on either side both sides
have disassembled warheads pieces are
kept in separate places partly for
security partly because we don't see any
reason to assemble them and have them
ready except in the course of building
up toward a war well that doesn't sound
like the American theory but that's the
way in fact India and Pakistan
maintained their Arsenal's so it's
rather something like this so again it's
been tested in the real world it isn't
simply some
idea I'm gonna close out here because I
know you'd like to talk and raise some
questions this is for it has comments
you Roosevelt in its purest form it
seems so simple
I have spent thirty years they keep out
this the sentence and what it means and
it means everything it's about the
fundamental change that came to the
world when we learned how to release the
incredible energies locked in the
nucleus of the atom that seemed like a
tabletop invention and experiment
experiment discovery it has led to such
enormous changes in human life and in
human welfare immediately and since 1945
a vast reduction in the number of
man-made deaths from war from a height
in 1943 and this had been almost a
exponential climb since the 18th century
as technology was applied to war to a
height in 1943 of something like 25
million deaths that year dropping off
abruptly in 1945 to about a million or a
million-and-a-half a year and staying
there ever since because of this
discovery because science went about its
work of discovering how the world really
works rather than how we wish it would
work that's where we are and now we're
kind of at a crossroads and we have a
lot of choices interesting choices
choices that could lead to a very
different world from the one we've lived
in sometimes this need to make sure
everyone's secure before you eliminate
nuclear weapons looks to me like the
idea that once we have World Peace you
could eliminate nuclear weapons but in
fact the two go together in a curious
way they asked each other the question
of what do we need to do to be secure as
a nation and as a people we and all the
other nations
people's I think we're a long way down
that road I think we're left with very
few areas and nations that are still so
struggling to find some trivial phrase
comfort zone for themselves but you know
what I mean who are struggling to find a
place in the world and a way to express
their their genius and their talents to
fill their needs without resorting to
war into violence thank you
[Applause]
Nick let's go over and have a seat I'm
supposed to sit on the right side
because my mic is on my left and it's a
little more attractive for the video
camera you sit there and this is where
the cards go
[Laughter]
I'm curious there's what nine nations
that have nuclear weapons the ones that
looked at it seriously South Africa
Sweden they build them and then stop
Sweden and the ones that looked at it
and then backed off what did they go
through and is that a model for the
future somehow you know almost every
country that has the industrial
capability to build nuclear weapons look
at them at some point or another
and therefore had different reasons the
most egregious example is probably South
Africa which actually built seven didn't
quite finish the seventh seven World War
two type gun bombs ostensibly so that if
all those forty five thousand Cuban
troops in Angola descended on South
Africa in the later years of the Cold
War
they would they said be able to call up
the United States and say by the way we
have some clear weapons and we don't
want to use them would you help us out
of this dilemma that's what they said
officially as their reason but the truth
is underneath that program and behind
that seven bombs for diplomacy safe
program they were actually working on
thermonuclear weapons more sophisticated
weapons implosion bombs and so forth
what happened was the Cold War would
ended and they no longer had a reason to
maintain a nuclear arsenal and they felt
isolated from the rest of the world and
in addition of course their government
was going to turn over to black leaders
one of the reasons they eliminated their
nuclear arsenal because they didn't want
them to fall in the hands of the African
leaders who were going to take their
place not a very attractive reason but
at least they got rid of the things so
that's one Libya what happened in Libya
I've ever had the technological
capability so Qaddafi kept trying to buy
the bombs from Pakistan and elsewhere
interestingly all these countries that
we used to call rogue states were
prepared to sell nuclear weapons to
anybody
certainly not to Gaddafi or a terrorist
group or all the things that were here
fearfully proposed we intercepted a ship
that was loaded with some of a q cons
centrifuges and so forth on its way to
libya and presented Gaddafi with the
goods and basically told him we're gonna
blockade you if you continue this and he
wisely chose to go the other way
Sweden is an interesting example I spoke
with a couple of Swedish scientists who
had worked on developing the basic
capabilities and knowledge to build
nuclear weapons back in the 50s when a
lot of countries were looking Norway was
looking Australia was looking countries
that you wouldn't even think of now
Canada was looking so I asked them what
happened and they said well we had
conceived of of tactical nuclear weapons
in case a tank swarm arrived from Russia
to cross our borders this would slow it
down they said but when the Soviet Union
got thermonuclear weapons we realized
the two of them would destroy a whole
country and at that point it seemed
seemed silly to build some bombs that he
said though but we learned from that
some of the things that helped us later
when we were part of the UN dealing with
South Africa to to trace and track down
their hidden program sort of something
good came out of it maybe that's a
Swedish traitor I've heard a rare but
but interesting critique from some
military guys that well his history
indicates that basically since the one
use in 1945 in war no major arm states
have fought in other words certain
extent mutually assured destruction work
and therefore that might lead you to
think that well if all nuclear weapons
were eliminated then the major
eventually now on stage have a nice
old-fashioned conventional war you know
we've really seemed to have moved beyond
that I even even during our attacks on
Iraq and they were far more destructive
of civilian life than I think we
acknowledged we have been moving in
terms of weaponry and how our weapons
work away from one of the people who
deserves great credit for that is Bill
Perry who was under secretary of defense
for technical stuff during the 1970s and
80s and who pioneered the development of
the stealth aircraft of satellite
communication systems for the
battlefield systems that basically were
designed to make war more precise and I
know from talking to Bill that one of
the reasons he did that was to make
nuclear weapons even more useless than
they are if you've given up on the
notion that the only way to fight a war
is to kill millions of people in the
cities of the world then you really
don't need nuclear weapons anymore
because that's all they're good for
three questions all asking a form is the
same thing Alex G Chris McCarthy and
Gordon might be can land can
decommissioned nuclear weapons be put to
good use others there any ploughshare in
this system was worth some wonderful
stories about the post Cold War period I
have about a half a chapter in in
twilight of the bombs on this a
physicist at MIT back in the mid-90s
about 1993 thought of the idea what are
the Russians going to do with all that
highly enriched uranium that forms the
primary in most of their bombs it's
dangerous stuff it gets in the wrong
hands and what he thought of was we
could blend it down to the 3% enrichment
level of nuclear power plant fuel
instead of 93% for bomb fuel and then
sell that to American nuclear power
plants and it wouldn't cost us any
the Russians would get the money and we
would burn the stuff up in a way that it
could never be used for a bomb again
today we've about halfway through the
Russian stockpile of about five or six
hundred tons of highly enriched uranium
and a considerable percentage of all the
electricity generated in the United
States is being generated in nuclear
power plants from Russian warhead
material I've told people that who were
very anti-nuclear and they said that's
the first reason I've ever heard well I
might like nuclear power so that's
what's happened to that the plutonium is
a more difficult problem but I think it
can be stored and in time we're going to
want to recycle it into nuclear power as
well especially with the new kinds of
reactors that are being developed here
and in France and elsewhere well like
you're kind of a liberal peacenik sort
of guy in some respect you're seeing
rather friendly things about nuclear
power here I'm very proud nuclear power
saying I'm done and I started out anti
you can find an article of mine and
playboy back in the 70s attacking some
cities for having a nuclear power plant
what happened I talked to the scientists
who developed it I looked at the
technology and I came away with a real
sense that it is by far the best
solution among other solutions because
no one solution is going to solve all
the different energy problems we have
for generating clean non greenhouse gas
energy from a small physical footprint
source that produces steady energy can
produce 24 hours a day year in and year
out the waste of which is very small in
volume and the question that of course
has come up most recently as
anti-nuclear people have looked in
stages of what might be wrong the
question now is what do you do with the
waste for that you need to go to
southern New Mexico to a place called
The Waste Isolation Pilot Plant which is
a nuclear waste burial site
that consists of about a two kilometer
thick layer a pure crystalline salt that
has been there since the Permian 250
million years ago and that is sixteen
thousand square miles in extent extends
all the way up to southeastern Kansas
this bed of salt is presently being used
for military waste because the governor
of New Mexico didn't like the politics
of putting civilian waste in his state
but they simply drill a hole they've
made tunnels all around under there
about one kilometer down they drill a
hole in the salt slide in a 55-gallon
barrel put in a salt plug when the room
is full they seal it and walk away the
salt and needles around these containers
and slowly crushes them and basically
makes them a coherent part of the whole
mass of salt which will be there for
potentially although I'm sure we won't
take other countries waste all the
world's nuclear waste for the next
thousand years could be stored in this
solvent but in fact as I'm sure you know
Sweden has recently begun building a
permanent waste in the Basel granite in
that country the French are working on
this the other part of this is recycling
the fuel so that 98% of it isn't buried
the 98% that's still good to make energy
you only burn up about 2% of a load of
nuclear fuel in a reactor in the course
of one period it's crazy to put all that
in the ground we'll run out of uranium
in a couple hundred years but with the
recycled material and the plutonium
included in the fuel in time we're good
for 10,000 years let's have the lights
up a little bit in here and cure see
what the audience is doing some of these
things that's one more point on it
because it really comes back to your
whole point here and indeed you said
during your talk that you thought the
Bush administration was encouraging
nuclear energy in India partly with an
idea to quietly encouraging basically
their new nuclear weapons capability
yeah so that's been the effect of what
they did is proliferation and automatic
byproduct of the expansion of nuclear
power if you're using that example it's
an automatic byproduct of a really
benign in sense of what to do with
nuclear weapons in the world the idea
that the good guys I mean let's face it
sometimes the good guys turn out later
to be bad guys sometimes bad guys turn
out to be good guys the fact is the bad
guys are the weapons it is ultimately
these containers of manmade death that
we need to be concerned with the analogy
that I give to audiences and I think for
me it's the most profound way of
thinking about this whole issue that
I've found in 30 years is the conquest
if I may call it that of biologic
disease of epidemic disease over the
last hundred and fifty years through the
development of systems for keeping track
of outbreaks of the disease of going in
and taking control of that area and
helping the people with whatever needs
to be done we have moved from a time
when the average human lifespan was
something like thirty years to an era as
you know where we're pushing 90 and more
and we did that not with elaborate
technological developments we did it
basically by cleaning up the water
supply by dealing with sewage by
vaccinating people and so forth half of
the American population today would not
be alive had it not been for
improvements in public health in the
first half of the 20th century a quarter
would never would have died before
childbirth age and another quarter would
never have been born so there is a model
and what happened disease used to be
considered a moral issue God put disease
on people and cities on towns on
populations and groups if they broke his
rules and as long as it was thought of
that way as a moral issue there really
wasn't much to do about it
it was when it was taken out of the
context of normative values and moved in
the context of basically scientific
values as a problem that we all shared
in common that's where the the Bohr idea
connects for me with public health we
all agree that diseases aren't a good
thing when the United States when when
the Soviet Union proposed the
eradication of smallpox back in the late
50s at the UN once the various countries
that were going to participate believe
came to believe it was even possible and
it had to be proved particularly in
India which said we've had this disease
forever once it was shown to be possible
everybody participated Americans went
into the Soviet Union to vaccinate North
Koreans went into wherever people from
every country crossed borders as if they
weren't there because it was a common
problem to all and that's Bohr's idea of
common security as well and at the same
time that was going on the Soviet Union
was this is the other piece of history
generating tons of weaponized smallpox
it turns out the reason the Soviets
proposed this was so that they could
have a world population that no longer
had any biological defense against
smallpox so that they could develop
better weapons of mass destruction we
didn't we didn't check for that
whereas with nuclear weapons I assume
that's what we're going to check for
it's just not reassuring ding there's a
question from Allison Smith are
biological weapons the nuclear I'm a
strictly logical point of view smallpox
has been eradicated right whatever the
purpose that's it was the the result
there still is weaponized smallpox in
existence yes in our labs and in Soviet
Russian labs and elsewhere yeah right
and are there the question from Allison
Smith is do we have treaties on these
the way we do about nuclear weapons
treaties on the biological weapons oh
yeah sure
that was actually the first major weapon
of mass destruction treaty that was put
through and Nixon used it was Nixon that
he used the argument or he was used on
him actually by Michael Mason at Harvard
who was the one who spearheaded this
this treaty that ask your generals if
there were a biologic weapons attack on
the United States would they use
biological weapons or would they use
nuclear weapons and the general is all
said well of course we'd use nuclear
weapons so we signed that treaty now you
talked about the you know could sort of
a sense of madness about all of this
don't you think there's a question you
sort of left hanging as the the hardest
case in a way is the u.s. to be
persuaded that it's conventional
capabilities or somehow sufficient and
my understanding is that the sort of
next generation of intercontinental
extension of force that doesn't involve
sending a fleet is sending basically
missiles that that fly rather than go
ballistic and can fly anywhere in the
world and then explode our with the
fuel-air or explosions like that and you
know take out a gerrymandered district
of a city basically in a spherically
surgical way or or a particular
installation somewhere yeah just I do
the trick does that make these things
obsolete now in fact it makes it worse
because it's almost impossible to just
wish between an ICBM with a conventional
warhead and an ICBM with a nuclear war
yeah but this is not an ICBM these are
things that fly well they they're not
ballistic but they are the reason they
do that is for stealth reasons so they
can't be taken out by space-based
defenses right the Soviet the Russians
have developed similar ICBMs or whatever
you want to call them but the real point
is their conventional warheads we can
now hit any place in the surface of the
earth using GPS within 2 or 3 feet and
you don't need a nuclear warhead to do
that you can use high explosives so
these things are obsolete you're saying
which the nuclear weapons are just my
camera they are but at the same time
introducing a whole new class of
strategic weapons it's going to
complicate things just that much more do
you think that is gonna be headed to
offers coming anyway this whole
negotiation that President Obama has I
think very bravely undertaken is going
to meet I think in this country immense
resistance from the military industrial
scientific complex and I don't use those
terms as a radical or something it is
there it lives on this money 60 50
billion a year
I just learned recently you may have
come across the story to John Kyle's
price for allowing this New START treaty
to be ratified in the Senate is an 80
billion dollar renewal an upgrade of the
whole nuclear weapons lab complex in
America now on the one hand I don't have
any problem with that although I think
there's too much money but we will
always need our National Labs to keep up
with the knowledge of nuclear weapons to
protect us at that level they will be
our deterrent if you will so we
certainly want to keep them happy and
building laser power systems and all the
good things that they're doing these
days but on the other hand that's going
to be the whole large establishment that
has
that has grown fat sand through the Cold
War as as kenan was talking about it's
going to have to be stood down and
politically i think it's not going to be
easy so it's a big big task and i can
easily imagine that we'll get down to a
few hundred weapons on every side and
stop there for quite a long time the the
image that i think of are those forts on
both sides of the us-canadian border
where the old cannon are still lined up
with the the holes in the parapet and
the stack of cannonballs is right there
next to the cannon but we didn't use
them anymore I could see us being there
for quite a while now thinking of your
virtual nuclear arsenal the co designer
and co-founder of long now foundation is
Danny Hillis who developed the first
major massive parallel processing
computer thinking machines and that was
bought up very early on by the people
who were trying to model nuclear
explosions and the idea was that instead
of this partly explained that dying down
in the last decade or so of the testing
is they were tested in computers rather
than in the ground in Nevada looking
toward a time when they wouldn't be
allowed to test anymore be told and so
it's interesting
I'm getting an Ender's Game phenomenon
this whole thing is played out in
virtual terms in a virtual Megadeth's
and so on the I knew Herman Kahn a
little bit did you ever talk to him and
her and Khan was this guy wrote a book
called thinking the unthinkable at a
time when some people thought it was the
most dreadful thing in the world to try
to think rationally about nuclear
weapons they wanted him to be a taboo
and indeed Herman said later that the
only way to really control nuclear
weapons is for society to basically
treat them as a taboo yeah that this is
this is repellent and it's beneath human
behavior to kind of play really using
them but at the time thinking the
unthinkable and starting to do equations
and it's starting to play out the crazy
but nevertheless operational logic of
second strike capability which led to
packet switching which led to the
Internet the whole idea of mutually
assured destruction meaning no
destruction was he on something he's
from in Cana here or a villain in this
story you know I looked his work and the
work of what I call the nuclear
mandarins it was [ __ ] and I say that
because the military was the one that
was going to do the arming and launching
of these weapons and in Europe for
example where it was clear to the US
forces involved in NATO that use him or
lose him was going to be very much the
story with the countries so close
together with so little distance between
the Soviet side and the western side the
military was going to throw everything
at once that was always the plan that
was Curtis Lemay's plan that was
everybody else's plan so all of the
clever strategies of this could do that
and this could be bad and you could send
a little message here maybe a little
white envelope around that warhead
baloney it just was never gonna happen I
don't know whether they knew that or not
they were making very good livings and
developing great reputations with their
elaborate sophisticated calculations but
they had very little to do as so much
did in the nuclear age with the real
world than human beings lynn eden who's
a professor at stanford and a
co-director of the center for security
and international cooperation wrote a
book several years ago which is one of
the most brilliant books in this whole
area
it's called whole worlds on fire and she
just
was that all the nuclear targeting guys
only calculated the blast effects of
nuclear weapons well they did that
because the tradition in the military
was precision targeting had been until
we couldn't hit the targets during the
Second World War and then we went to
area bombing but we didn't like it very
much and it didn't feel right and after
the war we went back to the idea of
hitting individual targets and they
tried to replicate that secure sense of
accuracy and and restraint with
thermonuclear warheads when in fact the
real destruction is fire as I said
earlier and so you would have 60
warheads targeted on every telephone
exchange in Moscow but we would say
officially we didn't target cities so
insanity coming from the insane past to
be quasi a sane present time as the
question you're talking about hard cases
how would you resolve the security
concerns of Pakistan and Iran now well I
think Pakistan and India have done a
pretty good job of beginning that
process really they got very close to a
nuclear war in 1999 and a bizarre
argument over some little piece of
territory way up in their Malia's at
about 10,000 feet and came very close to
having a nuclear exchange and it scared
them as it should have and they backed
off and we encouraged them to back off
oh and they have been working despite
some really deep conflicts culturally
between the two countries they have been
trying to find some common ground to to
work through and I think the fact that
they Pakistan up to that point had
maintained its nuclear weapons fully
assembled and ready to go and since then
they have moved to the Indian strategy
of disassembled delayed deterrence
basically which in itself is a great
step forward and are they mutually
transparent about that they each knows
that the other is disassembling yeah
yeah because I've read it in the open
press so I assume
mas so that problem is perhaps gonna
find its way through Iran is you know
what to say about a country that feels
threatened and humiliated and generally
disrespected that has been struggling
now off and on for 20 years to build a
nuclear weapon and hasn't even got that
far yet unlike their neighbor Iraq which
was much farther down the road this
whole thing began for Iran in the
context of their constant fighting back
and forth with Iraq and it's only lately
become mixed up with us points of view
in politics I mean I've had people say
well when they get a nuclear weapon
they'll give it to terrorists who will
attack the United States with it can you
imagine people who have struggled to to
hold their country together and achieve
positions of power voluntarily ask to be
nuked so that they can make a point
about their religion I just cannot
conceive it and I don't think anyone in
their right mind in Iran or anywhere
else conceived it either what I suspect
will play out will be something like
what's been going on with Pakistan and
India and the more recent what I think
of as the the new third tier of nuclear
powers or would be nuclear powers in
Southeast Asia and the Middle East I
think the the key note the key is
probably Israel and its nuclear
capabilities and that's why the latest
effort which Israel has somewhat
reluctantly agreed to begin to talk with
the other countries about is to move
toward a nuclear free zone in the Middle
East that would with the security
guarantees that would be necessary to
make that work I think that would give
everyone a chance with pride and with
dignity to step back and to I mean I'm
being optimistic here we've but we've
heard the other scenarios and I think
it's good once in a while to ask what
would be a good outcome from a
circumstance every country including
ours despite all the domestic conflict
over this issue every country has strong
reasons to get rid of its nuclear
weapons because when you acquire nuclear
weapons you make yourself a potential
threat to every other nation in the
world particularly the other nuclear
powers and that's not necessarily a very
comfortable place to be if you're
Pakistan or Iran or whoever so there's
strong motivation but there's also the
countervailing force you know the
Minister of Defence of India when they
tested that whole series of weapons in
1998 said to the press now the big boys
are going to have to let us sit at the
table there's no question that that had
a lot to do with a feeling of national
prestige that had been wanting and the
whole post-colonial struggle about
recognition as as a country of equal so
these things you know my book opens with
the sentence when the ice broke on the
river of history at the end of the Cold
War
everything was so locked up with the two
sides and everyone aligned with one or
the other that fell away and we are now
seeing all the rearrangements at every
different level that must follow in a
more multilateral world than we had
through all those years now you raised
in you're talking in the book the point
of that we're now in the process of
basically inventory and tracking all of
the highly enriched uranium in the world
and this is a step toward really
mastering this whole thing there's also
talk of fuel banking for nuclear power
of the basically low enriched uranium
also being kept track of in a sense by
push this young in Prague and so on
Israel finally wants a nuclear power as
well it's nuclear weapon so after all
this time Iran actually does need
nuclear power yeah and so the idea is
that if you can get an international
nuclear fuel bank going as part of a
demilitarizing D weaponizing of fissile
material right this this all becomes a
package so now does that make sense or
said it it makes great sense and I
remember when I first heard the idea of
thinking well that's not
and transparent but we offered something
like that recently to the Iranians and
at least in the context of the much more
dicey relationship between the United
States and Iran they really wanted very
nothing to do with it basically they
were willing to give some fuel to be
taken abroad but not all but United Arab
Emirates just said they would go along
with a deal like that and I think in the
longer run as these other problems are
adjusted for that seems to me to be a
reasonable solution ironically it goes
all the way back to the ashton
Lilienthal plan because that's the way
they saw international organizations
mining and making the fuel for nuclear
power rather than individual countries
doing that so are you so optimistic
you're not going to write another book
about well this book comes up to the
present I don't know all right Jen
actually count as you know I'm looking
for another very large subject that I'd
like to work on and I'm thinking about
tell us about I think about a book that
would be called the making of the
digital age which no one has written
pasta probably because it would be
almost impossible to write but that was
true maybe at the outset in my thinking
about you know when I wrote the making
the atomic bomb I wasn't going to stop
in 1945 silly me I was going to write
the whole story and of course my my
editors wisely said once you stop the
end the Second World War you can maybe
write about the rest later and I was at
800-page as a published book by then so
I did but there is a tremendous story
about another deep and profound
transformation in human life that's
involved in the digital process that's
been coming up since the late 19th
century and no one has written that book
so if I can find someone who would like
to help me write it financially speaking
because publishers aren't really paying
for books anymore they've cut their
advances back to the point where you're
lucky if an advance for a three-year
project pays your taxes in the first
year I mean so that people that Stanford
I've spoken with are saying well the new
model for writing a serious
book is to find a foundation that's
willing to give you a grant and on that
basis read the book and then find a
publisher if you can we're back to the
old patron yeah well in a sense the
publisher used to share the risk with
you by giving you an advance on what
they expected the book would earn but
books aren't doing terribly well they're
much more cautious than they were
they're banking everything on the on the
hopeless long term idea that if they
publish enough huge bestsellers by
celebrities that that will tide them
over when in fact publishers have always
lived on back lists the good solid books
that pub sell in here in and year out
for years and years the making of the
atomic bomb only sold 30,000 copies in
its first year because that's all my
publisher and it won all the prizes all
the prices and has sold steadily every
year since then and is now well up about
six hundred thousand just in English so
those things used to sustain publishers
and authors and that's all gone so a new
model is being devised so a final
question but that's I think a wonderful
idea for a book I would love to read it
compare and contrast your your sort of
motivation the idea that came to you to
write a book about the making of the
digital age to cast your mind back to
what motivated you to write the making
the atomic bomb and what's the
difference between the then and now and
those two that book came up in the late
1970s when it really looked as if we
were in an arms race to annihilation and
then as I was writing and Ronald Reagan
was elected and he really ratcheted up
the tension between the United States
and the Soviet Union so that I felt that
I was almost rushing to finish a book
that maybe could give find some ideas
for how to change everything and I think
it did by finding what Bohr thought
about all this oh that was a bad news
story that was a bad I think this is
basically a good news story but one of
the things that I know about technology
from writing about it for a long time is
that often the most
Manek part of annuity development is the
unintended consequences the classic case
being nuclear weapons we all thought
that they were going to be great new
weapons of war and in fact they
eliminated large-scale war and almost
eliminated us in the process so this
would be maybe a more
I mean my wife wisely tells me every now
and then don't be a hell in the hand
basket guy as you get older and and I
want to be the opposite so here's a
subject I think I could get into I
remember as a boy in 1951 reading the
new book I Robot by Isaac Asimov and in
my adolescence I and my friends got our
first taste of philosophy looking at
those famous three I forgot what they
were called rules for robots about how a
robot could behave ethically in the
world that was my first introduction to
the idea that there are ethical ways to
live so I think that that part of my my
distant past will we'll come back with
this book this will be an interesting
question it's how old are you 73
yeah and 71 and
I'm not entirely sure that the likes of
us can write about a really fast moving
current history domain like this one I
mean in a way the nuclear power kind of
rose pretty fast and the other weapons
was pretty fast and pretty much
plateaued and then it was dealing with
what it had a flow to it plateau - this
is a real different story
it is and yet that whole past is there
and many of the people who are central
to it are still around and won't be
around forever and most of them live
within an hour of my house for God's
sake so if I get old and crotchety I can
still drive my electric cart you know
down the road to talk to the others and
find out what they did a neighborhood
story thank you for coming tonight
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
you